[Music]
this is a big jeez this is a big review
today we'll try to respect your time it
almost hit me in the face the gaming
performance uplift of the RTX 590 and
rasterization for 4K is between 20 and
50% depending on the title versus the
RTX 490 rate racing at 4K is commonly 27
to 35% uplift depending again on the
title it's also uh without FSR in some
of those scenarios with FSR others we'll
talk about that today and then there's
an additional storyline to this review
which is that the 9800 X3
remains a completely insane in a good
way CPU it can keep up even at 1080p in
situations with the 5090 now that's also
where the 5090 starts to drop some of
its uh performance gains relative to the
4090 because at 1080p 1440p even when
it's not really that CPU bound uh the
the performance uplift starts to come
down thermally this card also uh just to
save you the time if this is all you
care about up front does better than we
might have expected even with all of the
discussions and showing the Prototype
and all that stuff so uh for GPU
thermals we were overall pretty happy
with it we'll show you those numbers for
memory thermals uh it's warmer than we
would like it's not dismal but it's
warmer than we'd like to see so today
we're looking at gameing performance
efficiency thermals Acoustics rate
tracing power consumption uh and the FPS
per wat number that comes from the
efficiency testing so let's get into it
before that this video is brought to you
by thermal Grizzlies aeronaut and
hydronaut thermal pastes aeronaut is
thermal Grizzlies entry-level thermal
solution marketed as resistant to curing
and for long-term endurance hydronaut is
thermal Grizzly's Next Step Up targeted
for overclocking and higher performance
applications we've used hydronaut on a
lot of our systems internally over the
years you can learn more at the link in
the description below first of all we
have a ton of content coming up so make
sure you check back regularly over the
next few days and subscribe to catch it
because we're going to be looking at how
this card specifically the founded
Edition model influences things like CPU
thermals not just the GPU because the
that dual flow through approach uh we
tested that in the past but now it's
shoving even more warmed air straight up
into a CPU tower potentially so we're to
look at that we have mini ITX case
testing with this model specifically
coming up because with again that dual
flow through a lot of the benefit from
this two slot design comes from pushing
the air through surrounding the PCB the
PCB centered now uh and that performance
is potentially going to be affected well
it will be affected when you shove a
giant wall behind it for s style so
that's some of what we're looking at
coming up we have pcie uh version
testing as well as a pcie Gen 5 card and
then we also have the tear down coming
up immediately later today or tomorrow
normally for these Founders Edition
models it doesn't warrant really much
discussion in the review of the GPU
itself this one does though we'll keep
it short the RTX 590 Founders Edition
moves to a two slot design and uses that
dual flow through configuration so
they've sandwiched the PCB centrally and
they've offset the pcie slots that foot
is offset to the side of the PCB uh and
it's down as a result that also means
that Nvidia needs a separate PCB for the
I/O at the back which feeds the monitors
connected via a flex cable to the main
PCB with the GPU so to get a twoos slot
cooler capable of handling 575 Watts or
more Nvidia is using liquid metal with a
triple Walt gasket to both contain the
liquid metal and prevent exposure that
could change its consistency and
efficacy the Fe model does a lot of
small things to improve performance like
exhausting the air out of the top of the
card you can see that here in ouren
imaging that we're doing later in this
review and that's actually really
interesting to look at because it pushes
the air this way and so it's moving it
away from the fan Inlet so if you've got
it socketed in a case like this uh in
theory it should push the air straight
up and into a glass wall and then help
basically pull it out towards the uh
exhaust fan if you have one in the case
uh that is imaged really well oning
photography so we're excited to show
that because it's that's always a really
fun test to run we have a full separate
video about the engineering of the
cooler with this guy Malcolm Gutenberg
the lead thermal engineer on the Fe card
he breaks down the changes check that
video out if you want more it's linked
below the Nvidia RTX 59 is supposed to
be $2,000 and will have official
availability on January 30th joined by
the $1,000 MSRP RTX 580 on the same date
Nvidia also has the 5070 TI and the 5070
launching in presumably February for
$750 and $550 then Nvidia RTX 490 had an
MSRP of $1600 then later it was
regularly priced around $2,000 to $2,500
due to shortages and demand and it's
basically out of stock now except that
absolutely terrible thirdparty seller
prices the RX 7900 XTX is amd's closest
competitor pricing is around 870 bucks
or so to $900 the company also bowed out
of the high-end race the 9070 and the
9070 XT that's amd's next cards should
be coming out sometime by March or so
then for Intel because they are actually
very relevant right now they're
currently only fighting at the low end
and the mid-range so the closest
comparison on gaming charts to the 590
today is going to be the 490 little
weird to to look at it that way and to
add some other historical flagships
we've got the 390 TI and the 2080 TI and
we threw the 390 in here as well then we
have the 7900 XTX the uh 6950 XT and the
7900 XT on the AMD side for the highend
for uh other stuff to consider this is
32 GB of video memory it is on now GD R
7 that's a big change so a lot of the
benefits where we see them at the higher
resolutions we think we're not 100% sure
we can't inspect at that depth but we
think it's coming from memory bandwidth
and probably from some of the cash
changes this is also a Blackwell
architecture solution so that follows a
to love lace that was the 40 series and
it's introduced alongside multiframe
generation or MFG and dss4 we'll talk
about those two subjects in a separate
video it's just it's too much to shove
into this one the 590 is also a true
pcie Gen 5 live device so we'll look at
that uh separate piece for the
differences in that as well now if you
want to see our testing methodology
we've published a test bench list and
the list of games and their settings on
our living document web page so it saves
time in the videos if you want to go
look at what we're using you can click
on that link in the description and
that'll get you the quick answers to
what we're doing for our testing and our
approach it doesn't have every single
answer but we're slowly adding to it
with each review cycle that has the test
bench Hardware the settings the games
and the game settings all right there's
going to be dozens of charts today so to
get through it as efficiently as
possible as you can
see I'm entering Rosman mode for Speed
here's a thermal chart running the RTX
590 under its autov V bios fan curve
with a Port Royal RT stress test at 4K
GPU temperature plots at about 72° C
once it hit steady state for overall
temperature when tested in a controlled
room ambient of 21 to 22° C this GPU
temperature is genuinely impressive
considering the size of the card and
that's important to remember at four
slots 72° would be acceptable at two
slots versus that four- slot monster
that we've seen for the last few years
from everybody this is an excellent
result given the size the point being
that even if it were four slots this
would still be about what we'd expect
and maybe that's what it would be if
they didn't use Liquid Metal our
prototype testing already told us what
Nvidia can do with a fully committed
fatter design if you're curious what
that look like memory temperature ran
warm unfortunately at 89 to 90° C this
is higher than we'd like to see
especially considering it could be
warmer in certain case configurations
with a higher internal ambient
temperature this is technically still
within TJ Maxx of the memory modules as
far as we could find so there isn't an
imminent threat to the card but this
would be an area for NVIDIA to focus on
improving our primary concern is in
HotBox cases specifically or small form
factor Solutions which we're looking
into as a follow-up that you all should
check back to the channel regularly for
but in most high airflow ATX cases uh
although higher than we'd like to see it
is okay adding GPU fan speed to this
chge the fans both hit around 1570 RPM
we should get to acoustic testing for
more on this we took the RTX 59 to our
Hemi an aoic Sound Chamber to evaluate
it a good GPU temperature is an
achievement at this size but that can
always be done by just blasting the fan
speeds and compromising on noise levels
so we ran the card at the default fan
RPM that the card set itself to at
steady state under our thermal workload
that we just looked at here's the
frequency spectrum plot in our acoustic
chamber with a noise floor of about 14
to 14 12 DBA on the day of testing the
RTX 590 was measured in our passive test
bench at about 32.5 DBA total that's at
1 meter distance the RTX 590 had some
spikes during testing including above
our frequency cuto off but overall it
has a very gradual curve for the plot
The Limited presence of Peaks and spikes
in this plot help illustrate the
relative uniformity of that fan were
noise which we subjectively think helps
blend it into the background more noise
is subjective so although this plot
objectively tells us that there's a pain
at 350 HZ and a bump in the plot around
515 Hertz and then again around 2,000 HZ
what matters is how that sounds this is
a sound sample for you to judge on your
own note that this is not identical to
the data we're presenting because we
have have to boost it for purposes of
being level with our video audio but
listen for the type of noise not for the
volume and you can decide what you
think so this is the SAR and imaging of
the 590 Founders Edition and you can see
our light source here and then that's
hitting the mirror and on the razor
blade next to it you're seeing the
bounce back of the light where we're
kind of splitting the light in half as
it re-enters the camera lens so this is
the schan Imaging setup and if we pan
over here this is what we're actually
showing so what you just saw I don't
know about 10 ft away let's call it 3
meters for those of you in civilized
countries uh that is the Imaging of this
590 Founders Edition card and
specifically we have it oriented so that
if you come straight on the card is
right in the middle of the mirror and
then these vents on the top which are
angled very slightly back are ejecting
the exhaust back the other way so that's
what we're going to look at with the
schan Imaging plus some of the other
flow through the middle of the mirror is
almost perfectly level with the middle
of the light source and as for how all
of this works uh I'll walk you through
the setup first so we have a camera
that's got some ND filters on it it's a
11/16th right now as for the principles
of physics for how this works I'll
explain it to you I have noing idea all
I know is we bought stuff and followed
internet videos and it works why does it
work I don't know but I know when it
doesn't work and uh this is what works
if you'd like to learn about the science
of it there's a whole Wikipedia page
really what we're looking for is we know
the direction that air is going to move
based on where the fans are we don't
necessarily know is how does it
circulate or recirculate what is showing
is the uh air density gradient or the
change in the air density so uh hot cold
air has different density it's cool
because simulation can do this stuff but
then we get to see it in practice with
the Shan Imaging configuration here it
is in our interview with Malcolm
Gutenberg he explained that the
beautiful thing is they're angled to
reduce recirculation so basically a pure
aerodynamic change to redirect the air
flow away from the inlet of the fan you
know the PCB is slightly larger than the
fan so then there is airf flow here that
is then
redirected those directions and then
when that airf flow exhaust we have you
know we have these um angled covers
which then direct air flow away that'll
be cool we'll try to see ifen can show
it yeah it' be awesome it' be awesome in
this image we're looking at the GPU
straight on with it perpendicular to the
camera Frost them this is where the fans
are off but the heat load has already
started you can see the density change
as the hot air leaves the card passively
as the fans turn on we see a sudden
flare up and movement of the air to the
right through the flow area out the back
and toward the CPU tower what's super
cool here is that we can see the air
kick up and out to the right at a 20 to
30° angle or so we can also see a really
high flow area of air exiting from the
fins at the outer edges of the heat sink
Design This hyper focuses the flow and
reduces recirculation around the front
of the cart which just means the whole
design is incredibly efficient at
getting air away from the board and into
the case exhaust fans here's the table
shifted to see more exhaust the flowr
area has super highs speeded exhaust
illustrating y flow through is so much
more effective than shoving air into a
straight PCV wall and this is a time
lapse with a fan spinning down at the
end of the load and returning to passive
cooling everything drifts Up and Away
this next angle shows the card on the
left and centered the most interesting
thing we see is this straight line of
air shot out from those fins at the
outer edges of the fan diameter this is
what Gutenberg was talking about in our
interview where they're capitalizing on
the area of most efficacy for the fan
blade finally here's the card straight
on where we can see the amount of err
just shot up and out you'll want to
choose cases with some spacing between
the glass panel and the card to help get
that warmed air away faster let's take a
look at frequency the next line plot is
to ensure the GPU is functioning
properly and meets the spec Nvidia
publicly claims Nvidia claims the 590
runs at 2.01 GHz base and 2.41 GHz boost
with room for that to change based on
the load assuming the software
monitoring is correct for this new
architecture we measured about 2600 to
2700 MHz during the test commonly 2600
to 2650 the RTX 490 ran at about 2745 in
the same Benchmark back when it launched
and when we tested it frequency clearly
isn't everything though it's higher on
the 490 by these numbers and it's common
that higher-end configurations bring
frequency down in some capacity it's
also true that architectural differences
make the frequency indirectly comparable
so this frequency number isn't
everything but what it does tell us is
that the card is exceeding the
specification advertised by Nvidia so
it's running as expected which is good
and now it's time to get into the gaming
benchmarks everyone is jumping to this
timestamp in Final Fantasy 14 at 4K the
590 ran out a comically high 182 FPS
average with 1% lows that were nearly
identical to the average frame rate of
the 490 that makes it 31% higher frame
rate than the RTX 49d for for average
frame rate to be clear for a quick value
discussion the RTX 59d is supposed to be
$2,000 with the RTX 490s MSRP originally
being $1,600 that it was commonly in the
$2,000 range the 490 is not commonly
available anymore at this point for a
reasonable price at least so just MSRP
to MSRP the 590 is 25% more expensive
and 31% higher frame rate in this test
the memory capacity increase benefit
isn't seen in this game which is
expected that'd be more of an impact in
professional applications like maybe
Adobe Premiere 3D work or machine
learning workloads the RX 7900 XTX ran
at 104 FPS average the same as when we
tested it in December so there's been no
change which gives the 559 a lead in
this rasterized Benchmark of 74% the
0.1% lows are about the same between
these devices at the top end that mostly
comes down to specific game level frame
pacing we might look at that later in
frame times in this video prior Nvidia
flagships include the RTX 390 TI at 88
FPS average meaning the 90 has doubled
that performance the frame time pacing
was excellent on the 3090 TI as it
closely follows the average the 390 was
more or less a flagship as well and at
77 FPS average the non-ti version the 69
50xt was also once a flagship closer to
the RTX 380 levels for performance here
the RTX 2080ti held a 54 FPS average
meaning that 590 owners would see an
increase of 237 over the 2080 TI at
1440p the 590 again continues the
comically high frame rate by running at
317 FPS average this has it about 17%
ahead of the RTX 490 is 272 FPS average
the advantage has been trimmed here
which could be because of an encroaching
CPU bottleneck or or because of some
differences in the architecture and the
memory bandwidth 1080p will help us
answer that for games like this you'd
really need a high-end CPU and ideally a
more intensive resolution to get full
use and value out of the 590 since we're
bottlenecks we'll move along but quickly
stop to look at 1080p just for fun if
you thought the previous frame rate was
funny Caster sights upon the 407 FPS
average at 1080p sorry that's that's
47.1 FPS average that was a that was a
close one as we all know 4 7 is below
the threshold of acceptability for the
modern gamer actually humans can't see
below 407 FPS average or at it so the
0.1 is what makes it visible to human
site that 0.1 FPS is critical and it's
what pushes it into playable territory
in maybe serious news the 490 is at 376
FPS average here that means the 590 is
still about 8% ahead this test really is
just for fun though it's a good reminder
that limitations of even a 9800 X 3D
will simply restrict how much you can
get out of a card like a 5090 at these
lower resolutions black myth Ukon is
relatively new to our test suite and is
tested using the built-in Benchmark we
benchmarked it at 4K for this currently
we consider this test in our suite to be
experimental meaning our confidence in
it is present but lower than other tests
as we evaluate its reliability we've
been moving toward removing its
experimental status with each review at
4K and where we've only tested a handful
of cards due to the Intensive load the
590 ran at 80 6 FPS average with lows at
74 and 70 this has it 28% higher in
average frame rate than the 67 FPS
average of the RTX 490 so far we're
seeing a few titles around this 30%
number at 4K comically the 1% lows which
for us is an average of the slowest 1%
of frames are higher than the average
frame rate for any other card on this
chart in fact the 590 slowest 0.1% of
frames are faster than the average frame
rate of the RTX 490 that's crazy the
7900 XTX is 49 FPS average gives the 590
a 74% lead that is consistent with some
of the other tests the 3090 TI gives the
590 and 89% lead improvement over the
2080 TI is enough to feel irrelevant as
a percentage but it basically takes it
from completely unplayable to relatively
fluid at 1440p Blackmouth has the RTX
590 at 130 FPS average 23% improved the
RTX 490 is 106 FPS average the low is
also improved the rapid rundown against
other flagships is as follows the 590
has a 51% higher average frame rate than
the 7900 XTX 75% higher than the 390 TI
ftw3 rvga 99% higher than the RTX 390
master and 189% higher than the RTX
2080ti former Flagship black myth won is
heavy enough that 1080p is still
meaningful for spacing even without r
tracing the RTX 590 ran at 160 FPS
average with good frame time pacing
establishing 127 FPS and 11 16 FPS lows
the 160 FPS result has it 20% ahead of
the RTX 490 diminishing the earlier lead
which was 28% at 4K 23% at 1440p and now
20% this isn't just a CPU limit as we
also saw in Final Fantasy but it speaks
to some other advantages on the 590
especially at higher resolutions at 4K
where we see it pull away kind of like
the arc cards we think the memory
bandwidth is potentially a large part of
that additional scaling the RX 7900 XTX
ended up 113 FPS average for performance
with the 390 TI former Flagship at 94
FPS and the 280 TI at 62 Starfield is up
next we haven't run that many cards for
this at 4K but we have a lot of 1440p
data we'll start with the more limited
4K data set at 4K the 590 held 108 FPS
average with lows that were within
expectations for this game the 490 ran
92 FPS average giving the 590 a lead of
just 17% that's lower than we've seen in
some of the other tests the lead over
the 7900 XTX is 77 FPS average is 40%
with the lead over the 58.3 result for
the 390 TI at 85% the 380 was down at 48
fps average with the 280 TI at 33 FPS
average AMD 7900 XTX and 7900 XT are its
highest end cards available for the
company right now but the 6950 XT was a
good deal in the back half of its life
at 1440p the RTX 59 ran at 147 FPS
average against the 132 of the 490 this
is down to a 12% uplift now the 700 xdx
ran at 112 FPS average a big improvement
from its 4K result as you'd expect with
the 480 Fe at 108 FPS average the 480
super would be around 1 to 3% better
here if we had retested it there aren't
many reasons you'd play this game at
1080p with an RTX 590 but just for sake
of sort of researching it and the data
the 590 ran at 165 FPS average here with
the 490 at 155 although technically
better for the 90 we're effectively at
the limits of the test platform here
Dragon Dogma 2 is up next this is
another one that we added in 2024 and
it's been heavy on gpus and CPUs alike
depending on the test area in this
limited Suite of cards we have the RTX
590 at 133 FPS average leading the RTX
490 by 35% this is one of the largest
gains we saw in our test Suite the 1%
lows and 0.1% lows also scaled up
showing that frame time pacing wasn't at
the expense of higher FPS the RX 7900
XTX ran at 77 FPS average with the 480
Fe at 72 FPS again the 480 super would
be at about 1 to 3% above that the 2080
Ti from 2018 ran at 36 FPS average and
that's without RT the Improvement to the
590 is
267 which is enough that the number
doesn't really feel like it means
anything anymore it brings it from not
really playable to pretty good and
climbing the flagships the 390 TI 64 FPS
average ends up giving the 50 90 a 108%
lead at 1440p the RTX 590 Fe climbs in
frame rate to 189 FPS average with
extremely well-paced frame time
consistency shown in the high 0.1% and
1% low values the 590 ends up leading
the 490 is 156 FPS average by 21% and
the 7800 xdx by 50% the lead against
these cards has fallen from the 4K
results although we're in territory
where it's not meaningful for the
experience it help us to understand the
behavior by looking at 1080p the frame
rate still increases so we weren't
totally Bound by by the CPU the 590 hits
214 FPS average leading the 490 by 133%
what's interesting is that the 490 is
now the same frame rate that the 590 had
when the 590 was at 1440p cyberp Punk is
up now we're testing with the Phantom
Liberty expansion ingame in the
expansion area the RTX 590 ran at 95 FPS
average with lows at an impressive 81
FPS 1% and 77 FPS 0.11% these lows are
excellent numbers and are similar to
what we saw in black myth Wukong where
the 590s lows are outperforming the 490s
average the Improvement in average FPS
was large at 50% moving from 64 FPS
average on the 490 this is the biggest
gain we've come across so far cyber Punk
is very particular though and sensitive
to areas of the game checking with
Wendell his level one Tex team saw
similarly huge uplift in this test and
in this area the RTX 490 had a large 32%
lead over the RTX 480 already as for the
older cards the 50 90 and 390 TI are in
entirely different classes the 280 TI is
down at 27 FPS average and struggling to
run although to its credit it's frame
time pacing in relation to the average
is actually excellent it's just that the
frame rate is low at 1440p the RTX 590
ran at 181 FPS average with lows at 126
and 108 the RTX 490 held a 137 FPS
average with the advantage of the 590
being reduced to a still respectable but
lower 33% the 7900 XTX ran at 120 FPS
average here which has remained a good
result considering the price of the 7900
XTX as compared to its neighbors now
that story is different if you look at
it with rate tracing but we'll get to
that later the RTX 390 TI ran at 91 FPS
average here with the 280 TI at 57 we
were fully bound on the CPU at 1080p so
we'll skip that one dl 2 at 4K is
another heavy load for these gpus the
RTX 590 shows a familiar scenario of the
1% and. 1% lows which represent the
slowest frames in our test passes
outperforming the average frame rate of
the 490 Nvidia has managed to move the
needle for at least the flagships which
we think is partly thanks to cash and
memory configuration changes the 590
leads the 490 by 38% another impressive
jaunt not distant from what we saw with
Phantom Liberty the 7900 XTX did okay in
this test as compared to the 4080 those
two are at least closer in price than
the rest of these but otherwise the 590
run 74% higher average frame rate than
the 7900 XTX however it also costs about
127% more depending on what price the
XTX is when you look for professional
users of course there's some more Nuance
where the memory benefit isn't accounted
for in almost any gaming scenarios that
would be more in other applications at
1440p the 590 holds a 216 FPS average
against the 490 is 173 this has the 590
25% ahead of the 490 down from its lead
of 38% at 4K we won't burn chart time on
it but 1080p is only about 15 FPS higher
so part of this reduction and scaling is
because we're starting to approach the
CPU limit Resident Evil 4 is up next
first rasterized and at 4K the 590
landed at 207 FPS average here with lows
running higher as a result of consistent
frame pacing the end result is a lead
over the 151 FPS average of the 490 by
37% a lead over the 7800 xdx of 64% and
a lead over the 480 of 101% against the
prior flagships the 390 TI landed at 89
FPS average giving the 590 an uplift of
13 3% at 1440p the 90 continued scaling
and hit almost 350 FPS average with lows
at actually ludicrous levels with 281
FPS for 1% this puts the 590s average
frame rate 25% ahead of the 490s average
frame rate so we're seeing a reduction
from the 37% that we saw at 4K this is
consistent with what we've observed
elsewhere the 7900 XTX held on at 232
FPS average here followed by cards like
the 390 TI at 162 and the 280 TI at 92
FPS average at 1080p we see there's
still scaling all the way up to almost
400 FPS average which is kind of crazy
this has reset our expectations of where
the CPU ceiling is at least for this
game and if anything it just sort of
shows how good the 9800 x3d is for
keeping up so well the gap between the
590 and 490 is around 9% here so we're
actually hitting external limits and now
we're moving to R tracing benchmarking
this contains games like black myth and
cyber Punk which tend to favor Nvidia
and games like Resident Evil and Dying
Light and also Dragon's Dogma which giv
some variety black myth is first this is
an experimental chart so once again our
disclosure is that experimental charts
are labeled as such because we haven't
fully finished researching them yet so
there's more chance of variable behavior
that we don't expect this particular
title is considered experimental because
his performance leans just so heavily in
One Direction that we want to slowly
accumulate results to explore it further
but does seem consistent with what's
online the 590 ran at idiot FPS average
here when we set to 4K now note the
settings and the title here this
outperforms the RTX 490 65 FPS average
result by 36% it's a big jump this is
with upscaling so it's not like for like
with the 4K raster results AMD 7900 XTX
ran at 20 FPS in this title which is why
we say it's Nvidia favored the 390 TI
ran at 34 FPS average here skipping
1440p and going to 1080p with FSR to get
more cards on the charge here's where we
land the 590 is at 158 FPS aage average
here leading the 490s at 120 FPS average
result by 31% against the 3090 TI the
590 leads by 103% and against the 280 TI
is 49 FPS average it's about a tripling
the 470 outperforms the 390 TI in this
test when using FSR with the entire top
half of the cards outperforming the 7900
XTX this test again is heavily favored
for NVIDIA with the Heavy R tracing use
Dragon's Dogma 2 is up next again we
haven't done a ton of 4K R tracing here
because it's such a heavy workload
normally but the 590 can handle it the
590 ran at 113 FPS average with lows at
97 94 the 4090 landed at around 85 FPS
average giving the 5090 an uplift of 33%
the rx700 XTX does better in this game
compared to black myth instead
outperforming the RTX 480 and 390 TI the
latter of which is at 55 FPS average at
1440p the 590 jumped to 165 FPS average
and the 490 held 136 FPS average still
keeping about a 30 FPS gap between them
or an improvement generationally of 22%
the uplift has fallen as compared to 4K
and keeping with prior Trends is
something that it looks like it just
does better at higher resolutions at
least proportionally and some of that is
because of limitations externally and
some of it is just because of the memory
bandwidth and some of the cash changes
the 7800 XTX does similarly here to last
time Landing just ahead of the RTX 480
at 1080p the 590 continues to climb to
194 FPS average reducing the
generational uplift to 15% over the 490
let's move on to something more
interesting here's dite 2 ray traced
again we haven't historically run 4K
here because only the 4090 and 480 could
be argued as capable and a chart with
two cards is boring it looks like this
next generation of hardware and
hopefully that also includes amd's next
card they're making promises about R
tracing is going to change that maybe
we'll see 4K more with this the 590 ran
at 109 FPS average leading the 80 FPS
result of the 490 by 37% the 700 XTX is
led by 137% amds publicly claims that
its next generation will significantly
improve upon this so we'll see where
they land probably closer to March at
1440p the RTX 590 ran at 176 FPS average
and held lows of 152 and 126 the 176
result has at about 40 FPS or 29% ahead
of the 4090 the 4080 hit 104 FPS average
with a 390 TI at 88 FPS and our 2080 TI
was approaching a decent frame rate but
still falling short at 46 FPS average at
1080p the 590 held 224 FPS average
mostly establishing that we weren't
bound previously by the CPU that's kind
of the real reason we're doing this one
so when it was at 4K the scaling was 37%
generational Improvement and then at
1440 it was 29% and now at 1080p it's
24.5% the reduction from 1440p to 1080p
isn't as big as we might expect from
other tests probably because there
remains enough GPU load to where the CPU
isn't heavily taxed Resident Evil 4 with
Ray tracing is up now tested it 4K first
the 590 ran at 210 FPS average using FSR
as defined in the chart title the 160
FPS RTX 490 result establishes a 31%
generational Improvement favoring the
590 the lead over the 700 XTX is 56%
here with the Improvement on the 3090 TI
113% we'll keep this short at 1440p the
RTX 590's lead Falls to 23% over the 490
this trend is consistent cyberp Punk
with rt Ultra at 4K is heavy even for
the RTX 590 when not using some form of
upscaling which we toggle of in testing
specifically because of how unreliable
cyberpunk sticky settings are the 53 FPS
average puts the 590 35% ahead of the
490 39 FPS average results remaining
consistent with prior tests the poor old
2080 TI nearly burst into flames trying
to run this holding an 8.8 FPS average
as it crawled across the finish line and
finally for the game benchworks 4K with
r team mediums interesting dropping from
Ultra to medium predictably increased
the performance but the Gap grew between
the cards with a 59 FPS average and a 40
FPS average result now we're getting
into efficiency benchmarking and idle
power consumption for this although we
tested a lot of games we're just going
to simplify the charts here and look at
a couple of game tests Plus Idle these
convey the whole story pretty well
testing is done by measuring the GPU
power consumption at the pcie cables and
the pcie slot with an interposer
although we initially had trouble
getting the card to work on the Riser
due to pcie generational differences in
the final literal hours before going
live here we found a solution to measure
through the Riser this testing
eliminates the remainder of system power
consumption so we're isolating for just
the GPU testing idle power consumption
the 90 Founders Edition landed at 46
Watts on the desktop with our
benchmarking approach the 590 Fe
measured lower in idle power draw than
the RK 580 and about the same as the
a750 even just sitting there it's
drawing a lot of power our testing uses
the windows high performance power plan
for benchmarking purposes so switching
to balanced may help reduce this however
we use that power plan for all tests so
these are all like for like comparable
we measured the 490 at 28 to 29 Watts
the 590 has relatively high idle power
consumption with our test approach and
this is an area where clearly there's
some room for improvement if only
judging by the 490 although the power
consumption of the TDP is higher on this
card Final Fantasy 14 at 4K is low on
results since we just started using this
for efficiency for this launch the 490
was the most efficient here at 391.21 to
produce 138 to 139 FPS average that puts
it at 03 5 FPS per watt the 590 Fe was
efficient as compared to other cards
we've tested here but technically worse
off than the 490 realistically they're
about the same despite frame rate
improving by 31% the power consumption
also increased by 37% the end result is
reduced or equal efficiency versus the
last generation this might be why Nvidia
is pushing the narrative so hard that
MFG improves efficiency except that's
like saying why compare apples to apples
when you could compare apples to oranges
in the very least against the 390 TI
actually like for like we can see clear
and massive iterative improvements we're
showing 1440p to get a wider selection
of cards although the lighter load won't
look better for the 590 the 590 ended up
around 520 Watts average for this work
Landing it at 0.61 FPS per watt
efficiency is down comparatively overall
since we saw the performance Advantage
go down when at 1440 PS compared to
other cards the cards should show the
best gains in 4k RT workloads like F1
though here's f124 at 4K with r tracing
on a technicality the 590 is the most
efficient in this test it pulled 569
Watts on average during testing it had
spikes uh not pure transients but just
spikes here of 580 to 590 Watt and
because of the frame rate advantage over
the RTX 490 with its 428 watt draw it
ends up at 0.21 FPS per watt instead of
0.20 this isn't particularly exciting
and we have to highlight that nvidia's
claims of efficiency improvements Lar ly
centered around artificially generating
frames which isn't like for like it's
not comparable the frame itself may not
be the same uh so overall it's looking
like they're about the same efficiency
as they were all right so wrapping this
up first of all we need to get into
nvidia's marketing because unfortunately
Nvidia has once again stepped on every
single rake that's been left on the
floor of a hardware store on its way to
selling its product that might otherwise
be completely fine this image shows the
RTX 590 as being two times faster than
the RTX 490 regularly but as you all
know from the revieww you just watched
that's not true this this chart doesn't
have a big title that says different
dlss versions where we needlessly
compare apples to oranges even though we
have perfectly good apples to compare
against each other nothing to be shy of
if we tested it properly it says
performance Nvidia technically lists the
dlss version in the bottom but most
people don't know what that means
nvidia's own line of gray text that
blends into the background of the page
at nearly the same color States the test
configuration this states that frame gen
was used on the 40 series and that 4X
multiframe Chan was used on the 50
Series which isn't like for like Nvidia
is generating more artificial frames per
real frame on the 90 than the 4090 but
they just list performance at the top of
this chart and say it's 2x Nvidia CEO
Jensen Juan went on stage for the
announcement of all this and deci said
that the 5070 will bring 490 performance
to everybody for
$550 which seems extremely questionable
wish me luck the decision to Market any
of it this way it comes across as
insecure and like Nvidia sensitive to
the value that they're providing like
the uplift's not good enough uh as if to
say the 90 it's not it's not good enough
on its own we need to put makeup on this
chart to just make it feel like it is
closer to what people want it really
comes across as just strange from Nvidia
but anyway enough of the marketing
the recap is this first up
users of vram intensive professional
applications should consider the 5090
for different reasons but we don't have
that data for you today not sure if
we'll run it but maybe in the future for
gaming anyone who isn't playing on 4K or
for higher resolutions won't get as much
relative gain out of this card generally
we saw 27 to 35% uplift in 4k gaming
over the RTX 490 in one instance we saw
50% and one rtn instance we saw 44% most
of the time it's about 30% better at 4K
at 1440p we saw that drop into the 20s
typically when not CPU bound the card is
one of the most power hungry idle power
consumers we've ever tested and it's the
most power hungry card we've tested
period the thing we're worried about is
that Nvidia has elected to push this
much power through 12 high power so's
some slot draw but most of it is still
going through through that cable the 12v
2x6 uh spec is a dumpster fire it's the
same for 12v high power we have a whole
video on it you should check it out if
you want to learn more efficiency is
about the same between the 490 and the
590 thermal design is excellent the Fe
card impressed Us in big ways and Nvidia
managed to make this two slots and still
in the 70s while not being ridiculously
loud it genuinely is an impressive
cooler they deserve every bit of credit
for that uh and that Malcolm interview
if you haven't watched it you really
should now because now we have the
thermal data to back up what he's saying
so that was nice to see as far as the
value we'll be able to more easily talk
about that next week when we can review
the 5080 for now andv video is launching
the 5090 first which makes it hard for
us to know how close the 580 gets to the
5090 we don't want to make a value
judgment right now when there's a car
that's going to be $1,000 instead of
2,000 uh and when the 490s are not
really available anymore to make that
comparison anyway so we're going to hold
off on that until the 5080 launches in a
week and we'll have that review with
that information for you as soon as it
does that's kind of the recap the
performance uplift is there at 3 35% or
something typically across the games if
you're in the audience buying a 5090
then we'd like to hear from you if you
want to either sell it to us uh or I
guess loan it to us because we'd like to
look at some more where just because of
how interesting this Fe model is at two
slots I'm trying to get in some partner
models of various sizes so we can just
see like okay so if it's a four slot but
it's on paste does that pull it to
basically the same spot meaning is that
the key to success here and there's
there's test we do on this card to look
at the two and we'll have that for you
but uh if you're buying a 5090 and you
want to sell it to us or loan it to us
you can email tips tips at Gamers
nexus.net as soon as you've got some
kind of confirmation you have one we may
not reply to everyone uh but you can do
that and hopefully we'll see it so
thanks for watching that's it for this
review there's a lot here to look at uh
personally I'm really excited about the
thermal Solution that's for me that's
always the most fun part of this power
is interesting too um and uh yeah we'll
have a lot more to talk about so check
back regularly over the next several
days for that subscribe for more and
we'll see you all next time